JK Rowling has Harry Potter fans going
nuts but nope it's not what you think
yeah 12 years after the last Harry
Potter book published the author dropped
a new nugget about Professor Dumbledore
that has fans in a frenzy Rowling who
previously confirmed Dumbledore is gay
gave fans a deeper look at his romance
with fellow wizard Gellert Grindelwald
in a special feature for the upcoming
fantastic beast the crimes of
Grindelwald blu-ray Rowling says there
was a quote sexual dimension to their
relationship that is some T she added
their relationship was incredibly
intense it was passionate and it was a
love relationship but as happens in any
relationship gay or straight or whatever
label we want to put on it one never
knows really what the other person is
feeling
you can't know you can believe you know
what mr. Scamander fears above
everything else is having to work in an
office sir now we have to wonder if JK
gave that insight to Jude Law who plays
young Dumbledore he told et that to prep
for the role he spent a day with the
author I sat in a room for an afternoon
with JK Rowling and I listened to her
extraordinary words of wisdom and she
was kind enough to share with me the
whole back story and her future hopes
for this young that character of
Dumbledore and really that set me on the
path I just did what the writer said
this isn't the first time that Rawlings
dished on Dumbledore sexuality in 2007
she confessed in a Q&A session with
Harry Potter fans that he was gay and
Dumbledore's loved her Grindelwald
became his quote great tragedy the
bombshell was met with mixed reactions
of course here's how the Twitterverse
responded to Rawlings controversial
comments quote JK Rowling just said my
parents have been in an open marriage
this whole time
sad face one user tweeted nobody JK
Rowling Hogwarts was super diverse
exceptionally gay extremely homoerotic
and there were a ton of black and Jewish
kids too I just didn't write about any
of them but they were there trust me
somebody ma'am this is a Wendy's
these are some crazy sweet they're
really good another user seemingly poke
fun at the latest College Admission
scandal writing this wake me when JK
Rowling admits that Harry Potter's rich
as parents bought his way into Hogwarts
by magic shop in his head onto a
Quidditch player that's kind of Awesome
props to that Twitter user he sat down
with the cast of the flick in July and
they dished on how Jude's Dumbledore is
different than the Dumbledore we came to
know and love in the previous Harry
Potter films check this out
he's still mischievous and he can be
manipulative he has a great friendship
with new who knew that Johnny Depp was
coming did anybody know are you shook
over this news as much as fans are of
course we'll keep you updated with all
the latest in Rowling shares more
Hogwarts hidden secrets be sure to
subscribe to ET for all the latest until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens and I'm
Courtney teza know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]